this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby Kelly Ripa's husband Mark
has always looked good I met Mark 25
years ago and he was like he had played
soccer no I need to get his dentist he
was such a status information I remember
she was she was the best looking she was
the coolest funniest hottest she's super
gal ever when 25 years ago I remember
going well I want to marry her because
I'm I would marry I'd move her in my
house right now what happened because
Mark because I'm not Mark's Consuelo and
I'm a piece of [__] that's why but
otherwise I just want to hear you say I
knew yeah yeah yeah because obviously
yeah Kelly Ripa come on come on dude I
was cute when I was younger yummy Keller
just saw him in the mirror next to me
and I was like you're enormous and he
goes yeah you're you're small what are
you shaking up this is Magic mine you
want to try some it's a it's a nootropic
but it's like really really good
I this guy invented it he had harp
trouble he he he's a huge Tech guy so
you're gonna tell me a pseudoscience no
no no no he he said how do I how do I
get like five hours of energy without
try that tell me what you think it makes
your coffee last all day
it doesn't these are these are
adaptogens mushrooms uh matcha all kinds
of things trust me it's great I love it
let me take it every day it doesn't make
it like your pants
Jitters yeah it's all natural and
there's about 10 years worth of Science
in it
give it a shot
yeah you about to you about to you about
I feel like that hurts the cause
Ayahuasca and you're like what the hell
just trust me that's where we're at with
Society yeah there's 10 years of science
even when I heard them like I wouldn't
take it yeah
yeah
I want you to take and tell me what you
think
so it's not a like uh it's not like a
hallucinogen no no no no no no no it's
literally like a magic mushroom through
me yeah yeah it's like a natural
five-hour energy thing Stephen do you
have a black guy right now or is my
vision bad
no you're good well it must be the life
of your vision's bad but no you don't
have a little bit of a black guy it
might be the shadow let me see does it
look on your eyes angles is it our
lighting yes
that's from holding a scope against his
eyes I don't want people to think you
got that's what all the murder I don't
think he has black basketball lighting
it's from all the murder he does
you know my nickname not my nickname
I've been hunting with Stephen four
times now yeah do you consider it might
go hiker
you are the inconsiderate Mountain go
hike yeah no I asked some someone made
me some merch that said that on it well
because it's only one thing what is it
it's like your T-shirt yeah well
you take us you take us to like wherever
the most uncomfortable place is if
there's a trail Steve rinella goes no
I'm not going to do the trail let's walk
through the thorn bushes make a little
water and then he goes let's set up
let's sleep in water it's better to be
wet the whole time because you want to
be miserable I dig it and he never gets
tired he's a mountain goat and Rogan and
I are just
it's just unbelievable how's Rogan with
it with the hiking because he has
shorter legs yeah you can hear him
breathing we don't see any animals you
don't have a dog I can't I've never done
with I haven't done a real long
like a real long hike with Joe to find
Long
well 12 miles well I don't know that's
his long
yeah that'd be that's a good hike watch
this watch this ready but then it's like
to do that I would think if you if to
hike that far a number of days in a row
I would regard as a good that's a good
height
with elevation yeah right uh they call
me the cashmere killer because I bring I
wear cashmere but then they called me
Deadeye because I can see everything I
don't need to classify did Brian kill
anything when he went Stephen even with
your help did it yeah killed uh no no
let him answer let him answer he knows
no no I sent you pictures
the first time we went when we met you
got a deer you got a deal dear you got a
baby there's a spot on the horizon I
dropped that bad boy my uh my finger was
steady I became one with the deer I
could feel its heartbeat and that that
was linked up through uh meat eaters is
that how you meat eater yeah so that's
how we met we met well I I went on Joe's
podcast
in fact I always tell people this
um
the first time I ever heard the word
podcast was in context
of Joe's show makes sense
um yeah I didn't know
who he was or what it was you just got
an invite to come on the show yeah it uh
uh a friend of mine Helen Cho was like
you really need to go and I'll go with
you that she took me so we went to Joe
show and then I did Joe show one or two
times I can't remember how long sorry
how long ago oh over a decade yeah oh so
right at the start a long time ago yeah
and um
and we we hit it off talk about hunting
he was interested in hunting so I took
him uh I think he was so new to it I
think you might have been yes but he
hadn't been he hadn't been hunting he
hadn't been so he wanted to bring you
because he likes hanging out with you
yep and I remember he said he sent me a
a video of you when I when you were
doing a book signing and a vegan uh
rather Millicent vegan no he was chill
he was chilled he was thoughtful but I
but Joe said watch this guy how he
responds to this vegan he's very
thoughtful as a person what'd the vegan
do well he just kind of challenged
Stephen but Steven said look I'm I'm I
respect your stance
but I have a feeling that you don't know
as much about animals as I do and I
don't you know you kind of made this
case which is to be a good Hunter you've
got to have tremendous respect for
animal behavior and understand animal
behavior and and it's habitat and you
made this great sort of argument for it
which I think convinced him it kind of
like it was a really awesome experience
and then did you say and also because
you're vegan you probably don't have the
energy if we get in a fight he did he
looked he didn't look like a super
energetic Feller but uh that's my that's
my joke to this guy's credit so this
dude he totally played by the rules this
is also a long time ago but I was
promoting a book I was in New York it
was in a bookstore
he waited till the question part
raised his hand and asked a question
good for him it wasn't like you know he
didn't storm in yeah or like you know
just disrupting or throwing [__] he
excuse me would you say like any
questions
he had a question it was you know don't
you think this is all a justification
rationalization and then had a pamphlet
he wanted me to you know you could do
you know I mean we didn't become buddies
I did I told him I'd read his pamphlet I
read his pamphlet but no he didn't do
anything like
he was he did just what he's supposed to
do here's what you should do on your
show you should have a segment dedicated
you invite vegans you guys go out way
out do some Alpine hunting you're way
out in the wilderness they bring
broccoli you bring meat and we see how
long it takes for them to [__] die
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah maybe
because you're not going to last that
some badass vegans out there but yeah I
think so you know there's some gnarly
vegans I do a body of mine you have to
be specific about how you eat though A
buddy of mine was telling me that uh
yeah I don't think about vegans come up
a lot I don't think
about them a bunch uh me neither but I
don't think it's unhealthy I think you
can be really healthy and be a vegan a
buddy right he he had a friend who was a
mountaineer and he was vegan this friend
would uh according to my body this
friend would drink
olive oil
hmm
just is trying to think of a way to
gangster yeah you mean he was a vegan
and he was a vegan yeah so he would for
he would he would drink slugs of olive
oil
have you ever tried have you know
who are vegans
is that a dumb question in what regard I
know there are athletes who are vegans
in the NFL or yeah no way no no because
they like to win
it'd be tough man I do think that you
can be very healthy and be a vegan
obviously but it's a lot of work I would
imagine you can get a lot of what you
need from
yeah I mean even if every if if I if if
half
I don't know what percent
if I was the only person who wasn't a
vegan
it wouldn't bother me right if it didn't
change if I was still able to just do
what I do yeah it tastes like steak I
don't eat broccoli but I like I like
when you said well I ask him what what
do you eat when you're in the mountains
and you need energy at night what is it
that you because when it comes to
besides meat you like I asked you oh
like what kind of stuff do we bring yeah
oh it's all kinds of [__] because I I
remember I said to you what do you do
when you're in the mountains and you're
really hungry and you know you want to
recover I was like because I was all in
the nutrition you go candy yeah so are
you candy like on on so we just got back
from uh
just got back from moose hunting uh in
Alaska so that would be
you know go go for 10 days there's
weight restrictions on how much stuff
you could bring on a super Cup on an
airplane
so what normal diet would look like
would be
uh instant oatmeal
in the morning
with little envelopes of instant coffee
then
[__] like uh miso packages suit packages
uh summer sausage cheese
and then bars sounds fantastic so far
and then at night would be the the
problem is so
freeze dry meals at night but but it's
hard to do freeze dry 10 days
yeah but if just for a couple nights out
backpacking that always freeze dry yeah
why why why is it hard to freeze dry at
10 days just after a while yeah I don't
really I'd love to understand better
what what happens but I mean there's
nothing more perfect for two days three
days four days but after a while it just
takes a it just takes a toll I felt
starfish and did you did you take down
some big moves when you're out there
yeah I got a really big moose man I'm
not saying this man they're cool I don't
mind saying I mean I'm so they're so big
I get why I'm not saying you like to
protected most I'm just saying they're
cool man we
those are mods no I've wanted to get a
big one for a long time and I've carried
a lot of people's moose but uh
it had been in on a lot of moose since I
finally got a real big one of my own
that's a lot of meat you like something
baby this guy went to this guy's like a
well there's the Moose antlers right
there yeah that's a big how much meat
did you harvest out of that oh my god oh
it's hundreds and hundreds of pounds
yeah how did you have hoof that bad boy
we only had to walk in a half mile oh
man
because that's hellish what are you
taking moose down with I'll shut down
the rifle
I use throwing stars
why would someone go back into that
moose thing look at the comment they're
first of all they're following you the
first comment is please tell me that
animal died of natural causes and wasn't
killed shut up yeah hey man a knife yeah
a bullet to the heart yeah that died of
natural causes then we proceeded uh
um but why would they follow you but
like I assume this died
is that right bro are those are those
horns not big enough you [__] one
upper because that doesn't it help
Steven correct me if I'm wrong but if
you take out the bull especially older
Bulls because they take out the the
younger oh no that's not that's not a
thing he that's all that's not real I
made that up no he's at the peak of his
like a bull that big is gonna
um
when you get it like with servids or you
know members of the deer family and a
bunch of other animals you get they
don't have a
retirement phase
so
females will but males generally go like
it's an ascendancy
to Peak
and then it's usually death like yeah
they don't have they don't have like a
period of like senility oh interesting
they just yeah they they rise rise let's
take like a whitetail deer which live
everywhere I mean virtually everywhere
you'd hunt whitetail deer at all 47
States or something like that so uh
they go go
and then they get to their their Peak
period six or seven years of age if
they're really lucky and they don't make
any mistakes nothing bad happens to them
and they'll be at like dominance and
probably do more breeding dominate other
males and they're just done God they
just die females you know females can go
on and on and on but you don't find like
with most these species like that they
wind up investing so much energy
for instance a moose so his rut is
September October late September early
October and winter begins winners
beginning during his Brut his breeding
season
they they more or less stop eating
um they're competing with a bunch other
males they drive themselves they like
work so hard during that period and they
get hit by winter
and they get toast damn they just die oh
they get eaten or something yeah they
just they just deplete themselves and
they're they're subject to dying meaning
if like point being like let's say you
take a sheep and a bighorn sheep and his
prime is gonna be like eight nine ten
years old
you just I'm not saying you I'm
basically saying you don't like if a ram
is at his Prime at nine or ten you do
not find 13 year old Rams you just don't
find 13 year old Rams wow they will not
be around they they just after fighting
and rotting they burn themselves out
yeah and get killed and then also
predation from you know Hunters but even
in areas that aren't haunted they don't
they go from Peak to dead
wow and mountain lions Hunter moose or
are they too big for a mountain lion oh
yeah where they overlap they definitely
would yeah especially calves Bears right
yeah
but look no that like that bull you're
not
if you want to control uh
if for some reason you want to lower
moose numbers and that's generally not
an issue you know because there's not a
ton of
uh there's not a ton of agricultural
damage that moose cause
around municipalities you might
sometimes want to lower moose numbers
just for the sake of lowering them
because of vehicle collisions but with
deer and Elk
when they get they become agricultural
nuisances
um and they want to lower their numbers
you kill females
good male or female you kill every baby
she's ever going to have you kill a male
you've removed one
and then all the females will get bred
anyways oh interesting so you don't
you're not like do it you're
mechanically removing one creature yeah
if you kill a female that's what you
could drop no yeah so if they want to
drop numbers it's getting people to kill
does what's funny is
I grew up in Michigan and in Michigan
they just sent out a letter
uh
the fish and game agency just sent out a
letter to Hunter's basically saying you
people need to kill does
like we're we're way over objective on
dear numbers and culturally people don't
want to kill those I was shocked to hear
that they're killing fewer does now than
they were in the past
begging people to kill females wow so
they want to drop numbers yeah because
you want you want them rack the horns it
makes you feel like a man and I'll eat
the shall kill the [__] out of a dough
it's so delicious the meat let's take a
little break can we take a break dude
now Greenboro North Carolina never been
there but I'll be at the comedy zone
there so that'd be fun and then then we
got some uh then we got some skank
Festival where's the skank Fest this
coming weekend uh next month I am in
Iowa that's in October that's October
13th in Dubuque Dubuque uh that's
October 13th and 14th that's just Friday
Saturday only the Niagara Falls almost
sold out Casino up there November 4th
and 5th Chicago and December and that's
it but I will see you Iowa October 13th
and 14th then skank Fest Vegas baby
we're taking over skank fish we're doing
a podcast live podcast it's gonna be a
lot of fun doing spots it's a Comedy
Festival we have some Comedy Festival
now we got the ultimate Hunter on this
show today but the food I'm here to talk
about you don't have to hunt but it's
just as delicious do you like
pre-portioned ingredients you like Farm
Fresh do you like seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep do you
like skipping trips to the grocery store
okay I like options when it comes to
options hellofresh hello hello fresh is
a menu includes 40 recipes and over 100.
add-on items to choose from ready every
single week they have 15 minute meals
you can get a tasty dinner on the table
in less time that it takes to take out
or delivery so easy man stop it also
stock your fridge with easy breakfasts
quick lunches and fresh snacks just so
you know just shop hellofresh Market at
any of the tasty time-saving solutions
to your weekly box how about that okay
travels from the farm to your door in
less than seven days yeah I'm on
Carnivore dude and they just send me
they send me a lot of meats well a lot
of meat do they yeah I'm like delicious
delicious I just don't drive one I am
one I like that very much look go to
hellofresh.com
50 T 5K
hellofresh.com 50t fat care use code 50t
fat k for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months wow yeah that is
hellofresh.com50tfatk and use code 50 T
fat k for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months hellofresh America's number
one meal kit stay fresh can you talk to
me about fantasy Guru I'll tell you what
it's fantasy Google I'm not a expert
like the guys at fancy group I can tell
you don't bet on my freaking Denver
Broncos who lost 70 to 20 to the Miami
Dolphins they lose 70 to 20. did they
did they realize 70 to 20. 70 to 20. and
they might they might see you guys me
neither at the NFL that's the craziest
thing I've ever heard in my life High
School game yeah against a pro team yeah
70 to 20 dude what this is we're what
we're on three
we're so bad someone's head needs to
draw no way around because I would
rather have him than Russell Wilson Oh
My and then also I see Buffs got their
tails kicked by Oregon so don't yeah I
was but don't take my picks let the
experts do it with fancy Guru I'm
talking about legit experts giving you
guys their picks whether it's NFL UFC
don't listen to me and Drake or Brian
count take the experts here at fancy
Guru and to get their picks and their
advice go to fancyguru.com use the code
shop for 20 off that's fancyguru.com
fantasy fantasyguru.com use the code
shop you get 20 off for the expert picks
fantasyguru.com here's code shop
s-c-h-a-u-b for 20 off
yeah great best meat I've ever had
besides the best meat I've ever had to
interrupt you really quickly was the
beaver that we ate at Doug's yeah yeah
say this all the time you eat the tail
no he trapped he trapped beaver and he
stewed it he stood it with potatoes and
carrots
that was the best meat I've ever had in
my life am I wrong about that is it
gonna meet her was it the stew yeah
beaver but you wouldn't know dude if you
made yourself it wasn't wood flavored
I'll tell you this I'll tell you I'm
hilarious today I I I want to get into
that to the to the eating Beaver uh
oh yeah there's no joke yeah there's two
things are Tapped Out yeah sausage bacon
when you're making when you stop the
sausage there's no joke that has been
made yeah that's right when it comes to
consumption of
uh Americans Caster what's the name of
beaver
American is castorius when it comes to
eating American as castorius or whatever
it is there's no joke there yeah I made
yeah Doug
on the Durham family farm so a few
hundred acres of ground Wisconsin
he's real aggressive about killing dose
they're killing 30 does a year off that
farm damn and you can't get a grip on
them the meat is so good I can't tell
you it's nice you can't get you can't
get a grip on they can't get a grip on
deer numbers around wow but that's an
anomaly most people don't watch people
when I was a little kid dude if you drew
a doe tag
you know because deer just have
whitetail deer just explode all over the
range if you drew a doe tag when I was a
kid you were fired up and excited
because it was so rare they've even now
some states have even now toyed with
these things that you can't that they
tore with these programs what you call
the earn a buck
they're saying to try to get people to
kill those
they've tried a system where you can't
kill a buck until you've killed a doe oh
dang but you can't get people to do it
did you not that you can't it's just
they can't get people to do it to the
degree they want them to try to yeah to
lower
deer numbers did you see the size of the
mountain lion that Doug I'm sorry that
uh Derek Wolfe took down because I
always thought mountain lions were 150
pounds top that was a giant this thing's
220 pounds when he gutted it when he
gutted it and skinned it I think it
weighed 170 pounds yeah like I didn't
know they were that thing that was a
huge now now Bubba um Derek Wolfe is six
seven three he's not six seven no he's
about six uh he's about six seven I was
looking look it up I was a 670 line
would be stupid he's six seven bring it
up right next to him
that's a big line six five yeah okay
there's no 670 lemon I'm telling you
he's taller than that but okay he's this
well what are you doing what are you
arguing he thinks this guy's six seven I
I I've worked out maybe I know the guys
he's not six all right but either way
that'd be weird six five two eighty five
about uh maybe heaven or not sometimes
okay so but he was hunting in Colorado
but look at that look at that line no no
so this is a huge line it was a lot like
he's seven feet they struck that they
Str all right he's seven seven he's
seven they struck that trap of all time
he was slouching around you and when
they measured him keep going no yeah
when those Lions get that where they get
that Ripple they get like that Marlon
Brando like Ripple yeah fat Ripple yep
on their head that's big but they struck
that line track where he had killed uh
that lion had killed a mule deer hell
yeah and dragged it under some guy's
porch
but I'm not like I'm like way Pro-Line
I'm not like an anti-mountain line guy
in other words you're not anti-hunting
them who who's anti-line though are
there people who are anti there are
people yeah there are people who just
hate predators
oh see I find it more intriguing like if
we go hunting if you're like hey man
there's this line killing people in the
village I'm like yeah sign me up yeah
I'm about he was killing deer in the
village yeah I think he's fine but
here's the thing but I'm all for hunt
lines look at this I think that Lions
should be like I like lions yeah we get
out there I like grizzly bears being out
there I like wolves being out there I
like there to be a lot of them I like
you to be able to hunt for them yeah I'm
not like a good kill all the lions guy I
have a thing about I don't want to hunt
them I don't like hunting anything
that's uh that I I wouldn't eat but
why'd you eat the lion I don't think it
doesn't feel like it would be very good
meat dude you don't know what you're
talking about is that right yeah you
don't know [__] let me help you I don't
know [__] be quiet all that talk about
all that stuff you know yeah mountain
lion's good you can eat mountain lion
yeah very good really and this isn't
just acting like shit's good that's not
but be right there I've never heard you
say one thing's bad though that's what's
alarming thank you oh I'll tell you
something I'll tell you because when
you're 10 days into a hike I'm sure
that are not that are hard to deal with
Goldeneye ducks are hard to deal with
mergansers are hard to deal with it's a
it's a migratory bird it's haunted you
mean just eating them or not just like
yeah you gotta it's it's uh what I'm
trying to establish right now if you've
lost if you've lost track of where we're
at here
nothing no no I'm I'm not like
challenging you I know you drink all
that mushroom [__]
that's in your eyes
I'm saying is you saying like I say
everything's good I think a lot of
things are good but I don't think that
everything's good I think some things
are hard to deal with so someone says to
me like cooking mergansers
um something we've never heard of but
okay right there I guarantee you've seen
you have the most you have the most
obscure duck there's one species of the
duck that you don't find appetizing and
that's literally golden eyes are a legit
duck of course I'm just pointing out a
handful of examples of things so if
you're eating you're eating it with some
lingonberry you'd be like is this a
golden eye but what but what big animal
don't is the worst to eat he'll eat them
all uh javelenas can be challenging
what's it happen the hell is a half a
Collard pecker you've seen them yeah
bring up a Collard pecker and don't
don't touch your color back don't type
that into YouPorn oh God that's of
course he's not tasting West Texas
Arizona that's a wild boar so no it's
not it's a peckery oh okay and is that
everybody thinks it's important
indigenous to Texas no okay well yeah so
what's interesting about these deals
okay so you have three Packers you have
the Collard packery yeah the chico and
packery I know and the white lip Packer
yeah the white lift yeah so these what's
interesting about these it seems that
these are
have have been in a northward expansion
meaning if you go back and look at cave
art
and other pictographs and things you
don't see them represented in areas they
now live it's like they've during the
during the historic period yeah or or
since the Europeans arrived in the new
world it seems that javelina have moved
North into areas they hadn't Oh
interesting where there wasn't like an
indigenous awareness of them but they
taste awful
I don't want to call the brothers awful
but
yeah oh here's something that's awful
coyote meat is awful yeah that makes
sense I don't like coyote meat I don't
like carp meat what's carp carp fish
yeah carp yeah that's bad well that's
globally that's one of the most consumed
fish in the world yeah the Bible the Old
Testament has all these rules about what
you can't eat like Osprey I think like
you can't eat lion it's all kinds well
you can only eat stuff that's got uh you
can only eat something you've got a
split hook right
you ever hear of the
um Korean you know about the Chabad how
the Chabad yeah
for you viewers at home Corinne's over
there yeah she's the only one that knows
what that is yeah so I had a
um long long ago I had a girlfriend who
was Jewish
and
she was a writer it just I'll spare all
the details we went to this place where
you go to these really
like hard hitting
traditional conservative
um
Jewish like teachers yeah but but they
would the Chabad were like traditional
Orthodox who would
have a dialogue with reformed or
non-observant Jews so rather than being
cloistered away they would engage in
debate yeah they would like engage with
particularly with with with
non-observant Jews or reformed Jews
whatever it would give you a way to like
for these worlds to mesh so I went with
her one time
to this deal and and at the end of it we
were sitting around talking and I asked
I was asking a bunch of questions about
hunting how would you
how could hunting ever be
um reconciled
with the Old Testament
uh
because if you get into Cash root and
like kosher Slaughter
um the animal has to be killed with a
blade like cut to a notch to the throat
yeah so I was like well how would you
ever hunt and he said you would have to
I mean if you were going to kosher
slaughter a deer
you would need to catch it in the net
um and captured alive and then bring it
to a
a kosher Slaughter too much work who
would do the ritual Slaughter and then
examine the lungs they were shepherds
yeah we're trying to make Bank bro but
what I was saying what I was asking
about this whole deal and I was saying
like
you know is the prohibition on pork
because of trichinosis and he was
careful to point out he's like you we
don't know
why God said what God Said
it's like not our job to cite to
determine what he was getting at he said
don't eat it don't eat it right we'll
never know why he said don't eat it and
so it's not about trichinosis or disease
it does seem to make sense like he said
don't do it don't do it but you can eat
foul you can eat for example you can eat
duck you can eat chicken but not Raptors
no they can't you can't eat Raptors you
can't eat Osprey you can't so in the
Book of Leviticus they talk about that
and that would make sense because Eagles
are scavengers yeah and they eat a lot
of carry-on and when you eat an animal
that eats carry-on which is also what
pigs do Bush pigs will eat for example
um anything lying around right so so
things that die we were in Africa and
this zebra kind of broke its leg and it
kind of died and it said the bush pigs
will get it way before the Lions do you
know so maybe that's part but you can
eat beer though right you just have to
cook it
can't meaning no okay are you talking
about according to the Old Testament or
according about any of that I'm talking
about you and I got one last theology
thing though okay please
okay right on on carrying and scavengers
but how about this one yeah no no smooth
skinned fish that's it I know no
shellfish right no shellfish no smooth
skin fish anything without so they
Define like scales and fins which would
be so here's the trick historically
you wouldn't be able to consume shark
because it was not a scaled fish but now
the new understanding of a shark's skin
is it kind of is a scaled fish
or you know so do you open it up so
anyways but again even that so something
you know you know what shellfish the
problem is you get a bad clam or a bad
oyster hey good luck with that that's
going to be a long day for you well I
need to take all your arguments down to
the bad house
bears are very good no here you have to
cook it well done you got to brine it
right yep
so I got this I I got trichinosis years
ago
from raw bear meat why'd you do wrong
well just being dumb
um we were even so even I know not to do
that but yeah I'm a city boy so here's a
couple this is you guys all got it right
four of us got it you know it's an
interesting story
yeah it's a worm deal it's a worm deal
so
the the state where I live in Montana
back in the
I don't know when it ended but back in
the late 90s
you could uh
the state would do
um
free trichinosis
testing
so when you killed a bear
you could send that bear in and they
would just want a little chunk they
wanted a golf ball sized chunk
of the muscle tissue and they wanted it
to be from the tongue
I think the tongue was preferable or the
neck or the shoulder
and they would send you a slip in the
mail
of whether it was positive or negative
but it was a there was a delay so if you
got a bear and you were curious if it
was positive or negative you would
submit your sample but you still just
had to butcher the animal
and get it frozen because you couldn't
you know you don't really because it
could be a month or two months or
whatever the hell it was
so one time the one one time I sent a
sample in
it was a big bear I remember we had we
took the we off this bear we took the
loins and the back legs for Rose and
ground the rest and I had 87 pounds
of just ground meat off this block some
bare Burgers you hear me out so this
there's a lot of wrinkles this story
it's a good story my roommate at the
time
who became a
he became a fishing writer editor uh Jay
Nichols he was at that time working in a
grocery store in the meat department at
a grocery store
he and I took that bear down and
processed the whole thing after hours in
the meat shop
well we cleaned all the [__] out good
right but it was funny because later it
we even had it where I did all this bear
meat you know when you go to the grocery
store and they got those little
styrofoam trays with the Saran Wrap and
[__] so all of our bear meat looked like
[__] out of a grocery store we even had
like we did that like foam tray with the
wrapper you could have a little label
and [__] you know we did the whole bear
like that man it looked amazing and uh
and then I get the results back and it
was positive
so
I bought a meat thermometer
and just started cooking it and I
realized that it's like the temperature
at which it dies is pretty low but this
is when you were a kid or whatever going
back your Gram was like really cautious
about cooking pork to well done that was
for the same thing trichinosis and it's
only spread from an infected animal
eating an infected animal they've now
gotten it out of commercial pork when
they got it out of commercial pork
is when they banned restaurant slop
so when I was when I was banned it well
so when I was 13 I worked at a I washed
dishes at a summer camp near my house
and when all them kids would come
through
we would scrape all their plates
into a garbage cans
and then every afternoon a hog farmer
would come by get those slots and get
that slop to fat and Hogs well it's not
that the food the kids were getting
served had trichinosis but rats and mice
and [__] would get into the slot oh wow
and so you didn't have a closed loop
yeah so when they banned restaurant slop
from commercially inspected hog you'd
like you don't get trichinosis from hog
anymore oh damn that's right when I got
tricked no sense 90 some percent of the
case is a trick gnosis in America all
came from bear me and I got registered
because it's a CDC reportable disease I
got registered in King County Washington
and the dude that got it before me
I think I got registered I can't
remember what year I was
whatever year I was there were seven
cases we were four of them and the dude
that had seven cases and you dude that
had it before me had it from mountain
lion what yeah so it's super painful oh
here's the deals we
we're hunting bears and we're like
sitting around cooking bear meat on a
campfire and it was raining out we had
to get down to our plane to get picked
up and we're joking about that it wasn't
cooked that well
and we're joking about getting
trichinosis so
so I'm with these I'm with a handful of
guys you know so Giannis was yep yep yep
Yani was there a couple other dudes nope
okay
then we're not together I don't see
these guys for a month
okay so I haven't been with them for a
month but I remember it was July 4
weekend
um
I am just hurting man like I can't
barely cross the street from Muslims
most lakes
and uh what's that you know right away
man
I I knew something was up and I was
taking a lot of ibuprofen and I could it
felt like the worst like weight lifting
injury spread across your whole body and
I wind up talking on the phone with Yani
and he's like oh yeah me too man and he
goes and
Mike
and then also like another guy and we
have men together for a month we all got
these same symptoms
okay and I know I was like I get so I
know I got tricked notes in my body my
brother Danny
would at the time hang out with the
state epidemiologists in Alaska
and I call that guy up and I'm like
here's what we all got going on he's
like yeah that's that's
definitely what you guys got going on he
goes go to your doctor and have your
doctor call me so I go down to like a
doctor just a walk-in doctor and I got a
sticky note you know I'm like hey man
call this guy and he'll tell you I got
trick noses he didn't know what
trignosis was he wrote it down on a
piece of paper I said it's trichinosis
TR right I spell it out for him he
leaves and a while later comes back and
he's sitting there again I can tell he
went out like they always do like you
know what he's like doctors obviously
they go read [__] yeah to find out what
you're telling them comes back in and I
can't get him to call this guy
he's like well the difference is he's on
the phone far away and I'm here with you
right now and I'm like just call the guy
so he he leaves again comes back he goes
sounds like you have trichinosis no so
you just take antibiotics I took a 1200
pill
um no one else treated it I was too late
I took a deworming pill and when I
picked that [__] up the pharmacist said
I'm not telling you what to do but I
sell this we give this to animals for
seven dollars wow go get it from a vet
yeah she's like I'm not getting into it
but I'm just letting you know that this
this is used to be worm Critters at
seven I don't know why it's 1200. I took
we all got better to say let me ask you
this one you know a lot about Native
Americans and you've written books and
stuff but didn't the Native Americans
did they have any restrictions on what
they ate did they eat bear did they eat
like well I mean you gotta when you say
Native Americans I mean you're talking
about what do you mean Native bro I mean
no you're talking about like hundreds of
cultures yes hundreds of cultures that
all had sets of
taboos and prohibitions but we were
taught before we started record we were
talking about the
um there was some very Avid bear eaters
I'm assuming I don't know I've never
heard in the I've never read the
historic record of people eating raw
bear meat right they cooked it but the
biggest the biggest most interesting
about like trichinosis Lions Bears is
what they're finding out now is it's not
to to kill it to to disinfect the meat
pork too if you raise your own pigs you
know if you're like a hobby farm and you
raise your own Hogs and you don't know
what the hell they've gotten into yep is
when we say that that you had to cook
pork to 165 or whatever the hell they
used to say it winds up being that it's
like a gr you gotta imagine as a graph
it's like temperature and time
temperature and time exposure meaning
will eventually
kill it if held for a long time it's
like this the instant it hits 165 it's
dead but I don't know what it is exactly
but maybe at seven minutes it's dead at
145. it's instant at 165. so you could
actually
with sous-vide yeah cooking and stuff I
haven't done it theoretically is that
just like a water bag you take you take
you put it in a plastic bag and you put
it in boiling water and it actually is a
really good way to make meat because it
really tender but it's not it's less
than boiling yeah it's less than boiling
sorry but it takes a long time because
of what water boils at 212. yeah like I
think the highest you'd said a sous-vide
wand is somewhere around 190 or whatever
but you could I haven't done it but you
could put you could put bear meat in
that water bath and get rid of it and
leave it in there at 145 and eat raw
bear meat or not raw eat rare bear meat
which I haven't done yet because that
just it doesn't it's not an appetizing
because of all this [__] and you'd have
to do the same with like lying like I'm
not talking about the mountain lion but
like African line you do you do the same
oh yeah I know that yeah they have their
own like we have there's like trikonella
spiralis and all these different
triggers and strains there I'm there
when I the woman that told me they give
the the same vet or the same pharmacist
that told me that they give this same
medication to to
animals for seven bucks but it's 1200
for a person
when we were on the phone she used to be
in the Peace Corps
and when they were in the Peace Corps
when she was the Peace Corps in Africa
they would as a matter of course go into
Villages and deworm everybody oh wow yes
just as like not even testing it was
just like the Assumption was you were
just going to deworm yeah but I grew up
overseas I had to be dewormed and I I
had I'm not kidding I had long pink
worms me and my sister had long pen
worms coming out of our ass so I grew up
in the 70s in the developing world so I
get such a kick out of like people I
complain about the United States we [__]
it you couldn't drink the water you
could you had if you ate ice you'd be
[__] but we I got hepatitis A I got
[__] Giardia I grew up with all that
[__] I had it all I mean I'm talking
about I saw what malaria actually you
ever seen what malaria does somebody you
ever seen that with your own eyes no
whoo I the you this guy had malaria and
malaria kills you know I don't know how
many people a year but he was he
couldn't he had he was under blankets
like this and I remember watching him as
a little kid he was going
because he was that cold it'll [__] you
up man he's like orgasmically yeah
orgasmic they call this right
oh yeah and it sits in your liver what
about the black plague did you see that
I did not see the back black plague I
did not see the black plague but uh keep
away from rats if you know what I mean
cover your wells
um
do you you don't you why'd you make that
noise when you because you've taught me
a lot about Native Americans I would
always like to listen to you
but they're all it's all over the place
right yeah because I mean I know like
about there's there's areas where I've
read a lot about
um like on the Great Plains you know the
black people were huge right some people
like the Cherokee really big yeah kind
of like the Maasai or something some
like people that white soldiers during
the Indian Wars would be very
intimidated by the physical physical
stature giant yeah but that's all I
meant is like there's some areas where
I've read quite a lot about uh
the presence but there's other areas I'm
pretty ignorant to it right you know
like in the Southeast I just haven't
read much about that other Northeast but
the Comanche the Apache the Nez personal
yeah I like that [__] man yeah yeah the
the most war-like uh were when they had
horses the horses came from the horses
that came from the Spaniards the
commands here or was it the Apache you
spent most of their time on the horse uh
we just had a historian on my podcast a
story named Elliott West that we talked
a lot about the way the Spanish horses
there was this famous occurrence called
the Pueblo revolt
when the Pueblo tribes
kick the Spanish out of uh
out of New Mexico you know they were
like in northern Mexico into what's now
New Mexico the Pueblo tribes had a
revolt and expelled the Spanish for
quite some time
and that's what initiated I think that
was around 1690 or 60 90. and that's
what initiated that spread of horses to
the north and it caused this really
dramatic
power
it uh completely changed the power
dynamic because the people on the horse
yeah like at a time if you go back
before the horse
the real powerhouse is where agrarian
you know people that would live in the
west elsewhere they would grow squash
beans corn and it'd have they develop
pretty like powerful flourishing
cultures
after the horse came into the American
West
no
emerge emerged out of that was
equestrian nomadic bison Hunters
and and Fierce and uh
nomadic warriors did you say ohgarian or
Aguero are you saying Aryan or no no
agrarian
Farmers Farmers yes farmers of the land
but once the horse came all said you had
these uh
you know you you had the ability to
create
you know like the equivalent of like a
mounted Cavalry you know yeah and then
you had this huge power Dynamic so you
had these tribes that like with the
Comanche they weren't
the Comanche came from north and west
um
the Bison right yeah well they they
adapted the horse they got on the horse
as quick
gave up farming
um gave up on having a static stationary
Village
and just became Riders and they lived on
Mare's milk and like crazy [__] yeah and
they were able to just to travel around
tap their horses veins the way the uh
Mongols oh I don't know about that yeah
no dude there's this is like the same
[__] though no I've read that stupid to
open I've in Ian Frazier's book about uh
Siberia
he talks about
um
that that
thirst crazed Mongol
Warriors would would tap a vein with a
straw yep
and drinks
and they would drink their horses yeah
and then they would drink the Marist
blood so the problem was when when other
when other armies would follow them they
would like lead them into the desert
they'd lead them further out but they
had to bring water and supplies then
they'd wait till their Waters and their
supplies and they didn't realize they
were drinking them yeah and they'd be
like
just suck on the horse
that's the exactly when you have blood
run into your body dude oh you can only
tell me what happens bro she is very hot
how did you become like the basically
the Michael Jordan of hunting like when
I don't know much about hunting but I
know you can I give you one thing that
he would do I'd rather him no no but
listen listen this is how good he is I'd
much rather this is how good he is as
far as a master hunter he would go like
this we'd we'd be remember we'd be like
at a bank in inko he'd go he'd do this
with his foot and he goes smell that and
I'd smell it and be like what the [__]
and he goes you know what that is like a
what he goes That's a male Beaver
marking is territory I'm like how the
[__] do you know that that's how but I
assume other Hunters can do that oh no
man there's a lot of people way better
at hunting than I am uh but how did you
how did you because I just talked
because I just I was I I talked about it
at a time
I talked about it in a way that people
weren't talking about it and I talked
about it at a time that people weren't
talking about it in the way that I
talked about it it's fair yeah there was
a lot of low-hanging fruit
you know at the right time you know like
you can talk yeah a lot of the things
that you know what wait what what did
you say I want to go camping hey he's
not a piece of meat he's just a meat
eater
I uh
you know we grew up doing a lot of
hunting and fishing and trapping and ate
a lot of stuff and I just talked I just
I wrote about that as a kid you grew up
doing this yeah grew up doing it God was
into it I assumed very into it so we ate
a lot of wild game
um in a different way than I do now but
you know like
but Steve your personality come on your
personality is also rather Alpha you get
in an argument with Steve it like but I
don't know but again that all that
doesn't accumulate but I don't know any
Hunters who are bad I don't know what I
mean by that is that he's very very
he'll he'll he knows what he's talking
about but he does his research and so I
think that kind of personality when like
if you have an argument with him about
certain things like like Joe and you had
that argument about how many people the
Mongols actually killed
Steve's not given an inch because I was
argue about that because that's not
something I know about well he must have
said something really crazy well he said
he that Dan Carlin said something about
a lot of bros a number of like there's a
crazy number of people that died and you
were like like it changed the carbon
footprint of the earth literally oh I
got it and you were like I I just have
some so so but you grew up you said in
uh Detroit nope I grew up in western
Michigan okay yo okay
yeah my dad was big
uh my dad he was born in Chicago he was
raised by his Italian immigrant
grandparents so he didn't he he was very
drawn to
wanted to be a hunter and fisherman
and and would try to be growing up but
very poor then when he got back from
World War II
uh
he was just all in and so by the time I
was born he you know he was a lifelong
Hunter so we hunted a lot fished a lot I
trapped a lot fur trapping to sell stuff
and uh in studied writing
and so
as I became a professional writer I was
just dealing with this as I became a
professional writer I was dealing with
this world that I knew pretty well
and and I hadn't
I didn't look at I didn't pay attention
to
what outdoor media hunting media really
looked like that much
so I just when I when I I looked more at
writers that I liked and movies I liked
you did it your way yeah and so I just
took this I just started writing about
and talking about things that that a
decade ago you know maybe a decade ago
or more ago whatever I mean I've been in
I've been in the business for 20 years
right
um
it just was not [__] that was getting it
just wasn't getting discussed the way I
discussed it at the time agree yeah yeah
look when I drink we take a break dude
because you get a break you know what
happened the other day and my cough and
I went
I wish I had a gallon of macadamia nut
oh you do you mean how about Macadamia
milk you want some Macadamia milk but I
all right dude I use a lot of it so I
know a lot of people use they a lot of
people use milk they use cream they use
oat milk all that stuff coconut almond
milk if you've ever had a macadamia nuts
the best nut it's a buttery beautiful
one with some of the most literally some
of the healthiest oils you can have
omega-7 fatty acids keto friendly oh
yeah and very good for satiety so it
satiates you when you're trying to lose
weight we gotta we got them on here a
lot of famous people are into longevity
eat their Macadamia sure man including
my year and a half old who had an entire
an entire bag oh my kids
they love them I love them I bring them
on Macadamia milk you can put in your
coffee it's 100 pure macadamias no added
sugars oil stabilizers or or
preservatives like the other nut milks
contained yeah but they're not crazy
enough to give away a gallon are they uh
how about this yeah the entire gallon
for free of macadamia nut milk that's
insane all you gotta do is go to House
of macadamias.com tfak No just add milk
to your cart with any products and use
the code tfak buy products I mean
chocolate covered macadamias The Salted
Macadamia macadamia nuts oh my God 45
they give you the variety that's the
best nut they're delicious I was looking
at how much they were macadamia nuts
were over at this million dollars
a million dollars yeah thank God they're
so don't don't it doesn't have to cost
your house payments again
houseofmacademias.com tfak and you get a
free gallon of macadamia milk when you
visit and then you were just doing it
and then the the man-eater show came
along that was right here so Manny is my
show that's your shame eater's mom
you're gonna have to get the name of the
no I take it I'd like to come on
you see the outline in the tent so you
can see the outline the tent and episode
one's called hunting [__]
no but it's the first episode meat eater
came about that was your idea yeah I had
done a show a really I'd done a show
real short a long time ago I did Eight
Episodes of a show for Travel Channel
and um
we hadn't even finished filming those
eight shows and we knew we weren't going
to be making any more of those you could
tell like well no no we did finish it
was like it was literally like we like
wrapped we like we literally wrapped the
eighth episode and we're sitting I mean
we like wrapped yeah it was sitting in a
van and got a call that was over because
they'd already premiered the first
episode it's like we're all set we're
also based off the first step was never
gonna happen but what was unique about
your show that I always thought was
really interesting that I don't think
had been done before was that you would
shoot an entire episode and if you
didn't shoot an animal that was the
episode and you still wanted that was
later though that wasn't this [__] I got
involved it's crazy you couldn't do that
at the beginning though
yeah but we didn't have the ability to
ditch we couldn't spend time working on
something to ditch it so I did this show
that I don't like and I wish I had never
done it but
out of that the guys some of the guys I
worked with on that
um a bunch of dudes that worked so so
the production company I worked with was
the same one that did all the Bourdain
shows all those years 0.0
and I was working with guys that worked
with Bourdain
uh Nick brigdon Mo Fallon Aaron Jared
Andrew Candace and when we got we we
started thinking like let's do a show
that's just really stripped down and
clean like let's just do like a straight
up hunting show Maybe
you know no one's even on the show
except you there's no guests
you know or we'll go with one gas and
it'll be really tight you know just go
to a spot and film like the A to Z of a
hunt so that's what we started doing at
the time I had a brand new my first boy
was a baby just a little kid and we
would read I would read them books
and I like to read them books about
wildlife
so
the meat eater got stuck in my head
because you'd get to the part about like
a Tyrannosaurus Rex
or a polar bear that's what the kid
wanted it'd be like this
meat eater
you know lives off SEALS or whatever
that's where that word that's so when I
when we're trying to come up with a name
for the show what would be my long
running hunting show
um
I was thinking about that like kids
books
it wasn't like a diet it wasn't it
wasn't initially meant as sort of a
statement about human diet it was just
like I just thought like aggressive
Predators yeah it was like Predators
right so that's why I named to show that
and then we went on to make I don't know
we made 12 years worth of episodes of
that show where's the craziest place
after 12 years or the most exciting
place you've hunted because you've been
I think all over the world now the most
impactful
the most impactful things I've done
um is a handful of times I've been able
to go
down and do
River trips for you know
seven eight nine ten days
um
in South America
with
um Amazon well one one time in the
Amazon base and one time in a
in in a river system that
is split by a ridge so a river system
that flows north
and not out the Amazon and our time in
the headwaters of the Amazon with like
amerindian groups yeah I know rivers and
uh
hunt and fish with those guys
who where you're hunting fishing with
people who
they hunt and fish 250 days a year maybe
too much fishing yeah and all within
maybe like a 50 mile radius
oh wow of their home
and and how you get and also your
hunting where your your dad
your grandfather Generations your
great-grandfather stupid fish keep
playing the same spot yeah like using
these same techniques are they strictly
fish or are they hunting and fish what
do they hunt man we hunted a lot of
stuff
uh one of these guys I was with um
the chimane
their favorite thing that uh red howler
monkeys really
um wow they're eating monkeys out there
yeah man but then other like you know
what earlier when he asked about when he
said when he was asked about like
native
use practices so I also got to a couple
times hang out for for a chunk of time
with um damn
hang out for a chunk of time with uh I
feel like he's easy to kill
what's that I feel like he's easy to
kill right yeah they shot they had a
shotgun that they were that they killed
some monkeys with when I was with them
not not with bows and arrows or darts or
anything but other groups would have a
taboo against other groups that hung out
had a tat they don't eat they don't
consume monkey yeah so you can get weird
diseases from Monkey like it I don't I
don't think that I don't think why just
they had like a very like fish Focus but
also Paka an animal called a pocket
which they also call lava looks like a
cross between a chipmunk and a deer fawn
just saw a pocket fish I don't know [__]
about it oh that it has three options is
that tasty yeah there's one of that
right there dude I'm telling you is one
of the best
craziest thing like cutest one of the
best most unexpected things I've ever
eaten and how'd you eat it they roasted
it
it's a it's white the meat on it is
super white they're nocturnal so you go
out at night looking for them wow the
meat on it was super tender and like
white white interesting dude when you're
out there in the night time you got to
worry about snaky snakes huh yeah but
you know you're up you're with people
that know everything so yeah they grew
up there yeah it wasn't being super
chill because they see [__] you'd never
see and they see it way before you'd see
it but when I was with this dude and we
went up to a anaconda
um
you know and he's telling me I mean
these anacondas you're look 10 12 13
feet long Lay It basking there do they
eat them no they don't touch him but he
said that the one time like when they
will use them is
old people can kill them
to get the fat so you know like the
hairy like snake oil yeah salesman
old people it's it's okay for an old
person with arthritis to kill an
anaconda to get the fat to rub into
their joints but otherwise don't touch
them
how on
whatever age you're arthritious I'll be
right back yeah so he was telling me
this dude was telling me and they're I
mean I don't want to discredit it by
calling it mythology but in their belief
system
if you were to touch that Anaconda with
your bow
it would it would kill it it would cause
it to slow death
you can touch it with a stick but if you
touch it with a bow it will suffer a
slow death so not to touch it with a bow
that's insane right he the same dude so
this is the crazy thing and this is the
guy you don't know this is dude I become
friends with this is one of the best
things in the world is like
uh what do you asked about why that area
I'm sorry new guy there's a friend of
mine his name's uh Alvin and he has so
he's got the name Alvin
he has an email address okay you can
email him
but he he's telling me and I'm not
laughing man it's just like just the
different world view perspective sure
one time I was down there and they had a
lot of white lip Packers around
not good to eat they love them oh they
do way better than Collard peckery okay
everybody will tell you that no I know
that
didn't know they love the way they they
don't even like the Collard Packer that
much they like the white lip pecker
might be on the light and they would
have hundreds of second slips and he's
telling me how
a shaman
from a neighboring Village had grown
jealous of his village
and had locked all of their packeries
into a mountain somewhere son of a [__]
and their own Shaman needed to
train
up to develop the necessary power yep to
unlock
the white the white lip Packers did
training take any sex I don't know I
didn't get into the detail on it we
don't get it but like that and and we
were talking about the plains tribes
sounds insane up there yeah the plains
tribes had a lot of there was a lot of
Mythology in the plains tribes in our
own Great Plains a lot of Mythology
planes tribes that Buffalo would enter
the world
from certain sacred mountains and when
they couldn't be found
they were in they would they would go
back into Mountains they're in
psychedelics yeah right yeah it is like
the [__] yeah yeah it's psychedelica
[__] right that's right it's probably
tough for you to be like oh crazy right
but you got to go with it you're like oh
yeah oh no with that no I was like that
tell me more yeah yeah yeah have you
done any hunting in Africa no never man
no no never step foot on the whole
continent why not
it's having almost a couple times I've
almost gone I want to go have you been
have you hunted Yak or anything like
that in the cold countries like nope
nope no but I'd like to go to Africa now
yeah because I met some dudes I I just
I wanted to go but I never could find
who I'd go with like a lot of stuff I do
like a lot of places I go hunt I go home
because I met people or got had people I
know who know people or know that how
about New Zealand have you been to New
Zealand because my body owns like the
more land than anybody else in New
Zealand I invited you to uh really hunt
Redstone my wife just yesterday brought
up going to New Zealand I thought
personally
I thought it was too far if I'm Gonna
Fly it's so far dude that long I want to
get out of the plane and there's people
with bones in their hair yeah I know
what you mean yeah I mean like to get
out of the plane basically like I landed
back in Montana except everybody's
wearing blunt Stones yeah yeah it's like
yeah it's a little New Zealand yeah it's
like oh you guys sound just like the
[__] people I just left I agree I
couldn't agree more it's like oh it's
like I could go down to the South and
they sell more is this la oh no it's
Sydney you know that's how I feel about
vacation they're all just too far to go
for like a bunch of dudes that seem like
me although I was in Jordan recently and
they hunt everything in Jordan in the
desert and you they do it year round no
that I would do that that I I got a
connection really amen if you offer him
one more connection you don't think if
you know it's the number one hand owner
if he opens up his DMS right now he can
get invited anywhere in the world he's
the number one Hunter on the [__]
planet if I may he knows the Ted Turner
of New Zealand that's like having Kanye
Western like I got a buddy our boy our
boy Jones owns five five people I got a
friend who wants to feature on your
album
I can connect you with the God if I may
sir the prince of Jordan and I have been
texting and I was invited there and uh
because I was talking about hunting on
Rogan and I'm trying to get Rogan to
come to Jordan so the king found out
how'd that go it was oh yeah I know he's
like get the [__] out no he's not that
no that's not true because he's an
American Hunter yeah no he's he he had
other reasons does he want to go to
Jordan he would do it too far
you know it's uh look at how long it
took two days 11 hours 11 hours I think
11 hours I've invited I've invited Joe
to go just across the border and hunt in
Mexico
it's a tough selling anyone to do he's
afraid of that but he would do Jordan
maybe but but the prince Jordan said you
got to come out it's 20 hours oh you
just pulled up the flights you book
right now 20 half hours didn't take me
that long I'm on so you're you're let me
do get this straight you're in with the
Jordan has I didn't know Jordan had a
prince prince Jordan you guys are like
okay princess Jordan so the prince
Jordan heard me talking you can't sneeze
or fart otherwise you won't get back to
America no it's it's a great country man
it's it's awesome and the food is
amazing but they hunt there and I was
there and this better one what were you
doing on me I was in Israel then we went
over to Jordan to see uh Petra and and
why did Romans vacation yeah vacation
and what's Petra Petra is one of the
seven wonders of the world it's where
they shot uh Raiders of the Lost Ark
it's the the all the they did they
didn't even know it existed until like
1840 or something
says uh there there's oh the built-in oh
wow yeah it's incredible it's [__]
incredible man I rode on a horse yeah no
so like when you're shooting your shows
I'm sure there you have like a staff
someone goes hey be careful of this
right what do you mean like if you if
you're hunting in the Amazon Brazil oh
yeah but we so just to be clear SoCal we
Mo yeah the the you know 90 perhaps more
than 90 of the all the shows he made
have all been
in in the U.S like we film in Alaska so
you know yeah like like I'm a very uh
yeah plenty to do here I'm a very
American type person preach yeah like I
I like like the reason I like it I mean
there's great stuff all over the place
and I just care though right well we
just have a really good system of
wildlife management that makes a lot of
sense to me one of the things that you
weighed into you know when you go
I I like I appreciate con I like a lot
of context so when you ask about Africa
it was
hard for me
that they man they have a completely
different wildlife management structure
in Africa so I've always wanted to go
but I wanted to go in a way where I
would be able to hang out with people
that would be able to speak about it and
and I would be able to see it in a way
that
felt very contextualized meaning there'd
be educational and not like someone
rolling out a
um
rolling out like a tour for me but more
like that you would be that I would kind
of like get a broader understanding of
of everything that you hear that goes on
meaning like the poaching yep
um how they
while they've management plans how
people that live there interact with
Wildlife how people that live there
interact with hunting all the things
you'd get if you went you know if I go
to South Carolina to hunt turkeys with a
buddy of mine like you kind of get sense
yeah you get like this sort of there's
turkeys and there's the broader culture
and and here's how people that live
there think about it approach it and
hunt for them and eat them and this is
what they're this is their families you
know and you see how they relate to
their environment
um but I finally now found I've met
some guys who uh
from Tanzania that guide Tanzania and
live in Tanzania
um
at least part of the time they live in
Tanzania and have been grown up in
Africa
um and I really want to go hunt with
them because now I feel like
by spending time with them it'll be
it'll help me paint a better picture of
that makes sense of what goes on there
so I'm excited to do it you know when I
talk about going the first time I went
to South America I had a friend of mine
who's a Fisheries biologist
she was doing work in Guyana
trying to catalog catfish species
yeah and so she have a catfish like she
introduced me to people there she's like
if you're gonna go hang out with these
guys these guys are amazing they know
their stuff and so then I went and hung
out with those guys so I I like that
sort of you ever come across any
arowanas down there in South America
yeah man we both we bow fish for
arowanas oh you kill them yep they like
them a lot he has he owns I have two
errors my kid's trying to buy one right
now do you really I bought it in my for
my son it was like this and I didn't do
my research on it and the guy's hey they
get pretty big man so you might have to
upgrade your tank I'm like all right
whatever a month goes by it grew two
inches another month two inches now this
thing I have a 500 gallon tank this I
have two of them in there they're like
this see he's eyeballing one he's
eyeballing one right now for 75 bucks
yeah I bought mine for 75. they eat so
much and they'll eat they'll eat it's a
blessing no they're cool but you have to
have a top on because they jaw yeah
they'll eat spot they'll eat monkeys
what they'll jump out and grab them yeah
bring it up well there's air
scaled freshwater fish in the world is
the arapaima but there's an Arowana
their tongues are covered in teeth they
can take 20 years
old and Charles in China they're like
super lucky they're called dragon fish
and they come in red they're about five
grand to get one here in America they're
legal they're illegal in California did
you know that no yes do you know you
guys aren't allowed to do that really
surprised okay all right man take it
easy dude you know what we're gonna do
no I didn't even say anything [__] I
didn't even say anything dude even
didn't know about everyone like that all
right marijuana's dude you're getting
becoming gold you're getting worked up
bro yeah sorry man I'm sorry I was
talking arowanas all right yeah the
makushi people the bakushies
I didn't know that I'm glad to hear that
if you wouldn't mind I would I'd like
you to text me a photo of your Air1 set
up because my boy is real hot on
everyone you know what what's cool about
them is you don't need a real deep tank
because they just stay at the surface
and go back they swim laps back and
forth so I had I had the juvenile on
like 100 gallon tank and then I expand
to 500 gallon tank and they just swim
laps you just throw monkeys and [__] in
there and yep it's really expensive he
throws red howlers in here hey that was
a mistake Steve my son doesn't even care
about him now I take care of him full
time that's right I post a video this
morning and I have a catfish in there
again bottom is a juvenile in in a month
he's already like this yeah they just
get big man but they arowana that's
they're lucky too since I bought them
it's been pretty lucky it's more rough
years dude he uses him to keep his blood
pressure and of course very rough year
someone stole money from us that's right
but you know what the arrow you got
money stolen from you oh but you know
what I come from the doctor School of
learning good good
yeah that's what we say a lot of money
the arowanas were bad luck
they're supposed to bring good luck too
you've been tough this year though yeah
maybe what they get bigger would be
better yeah but you know the dawn always
comes before the darkest hour of night
yeah I'm just glad you didn't know that
that's cool no that's not true oh [__]
that sucks Dawn the dawn is when the
night wraps it up yeah [__]
there it goes again Steve rinella
[__] clip my wings every time I think
I can soar I got my wings clipped now
I'm back to waddling around the Old Farm
I sometimes wish I would have just done
it just to have it be over with Manny
yeah best meat in the world is Elk still
if if I was gonna eat one thing uh
we play this game all the time at our
dinner table if I was gonna eat one
thing it would be I would just eat mule
deer the old deer I've never had no deal
ah it's so delicious before you go
what's the weirdest thing you've ever
eaten
monkeys
like dogs domestic dogs and monkeys what
kind of dog come like a lab or whatever
no the dogs I ate the oh no the dogs ate
would look like a lot like you know if
you go to a place where you'd have
Street dogs
and there's no
there's no um
kind of controlled there's no controlled
breeding you know like people it's not
that people are like
having labs and like breeding you don't
need you don't need pure breed dogs of
course either if you took a bunch of
dogs and let them run for generations
and generations unchecked by
contemporary dog breeding you'd wind up
with this like semi pit bullish looking
oh
yeah like you know it's different
different parts of the world it's always
different what part of the world well
I'll take five thousand Alex no I ate
dogs in I ate dog in Vietnam and I did
it very deliberately and I was writing a
story for I was I was a correspondent
for outside magazine and I was writing a
story
about
it kind of came out of do you remember
like years ago I can't remember who
I can't remember what country hosted the
Olympics
and it was a big stir because they made
all the Korea yeah they made all the dog
meat vendors shut down yeah during the
Olympics and it was a big stir
and that got me interested and so
I went to Hanoi
um
what I was raised to call Saigon
not known as Ho Chi Minh City uh I went
there I went to natrang
in Vietnam all these places that went
right at the Lunar New Year
and in the lead up to the Lunar New Year
it's customary
especially in the north it's customary
to
like
it's a very auspicious time to eat dog
meat because it is regarded as a as a
hot food meaning um like it can generate
a lot of activity like I had a guy
explain to me
sexual like yeah the guy a guy explained
to me that yeah he explained me I was
never able to have children
and I he like rolled the dice and ate
dog
and then he and his wife had a child
yeah and now he can't eat dog again
because he ate and it like shifted his
life she yeah and to it would be like
playing with fire to do it again because
you could shift it back interesting and
so in the lead up to the Lunar New Year
you know it's funny you know that Lake
they fished John McCain out of
when he was shot down over Hanoi yeah
that Lake part of that lake is just
ringed with seasonal what they call fit
chill meat dog is a part of that lake is
just ringed with seasonal dog
restaurants damn yeah and you'd go in
and it'd be like it'd be common to go in
and have dogs seven ways
and some of the dishes would be these
paws like a puppy paw suit
and you'd have all these different
preparations
yeah all these preparations I had my
wife with me we weren't married at the
time man and shoot
toughed it out and I ate it for a whole
I ate it every night for a week
interesting and it was no you know what
I still couldn't tell you what it tastes
like because it was like
yeah they call it hot food and I would
get hot from guilt that makes sense like
sweating and they'd be like see
it's hot it's like it stirs you up I'm
like dude my stir up is not yourself
yeah you kill a dog in America and
you're done I know dude I'm like I'm
sweating for like way different reasons
yeah it's really this is not sexual for
me it's so interesting yeah it was I
couldn't get used to it and it was like
um
it's funny because I used to have I had
this friend that uh she had this dog
that had been shot in the hip uh it was
she had a dog that she found it was a
wild running wild dog and at some point
in time I got shot in the hip and had a
paralyzed back leg
and I used to take that dog and I put
that dog in my lap and you could like
tickle Its Ribs and that paralyzed leg
and stick out and we used to act like it
was like the whammy bar on a guitar so
anyways you like work the dog's teeth as
the Frets and the way antibiard be his
paralyzed leg
and every time I ate that puppy paw soup
I think about that pouring
I couldn't get out of my with my poor
dog
American it's freaking tough oh yeah but
you know what dude like that's the thing
is you get in other places and there's
this like this there's just that's kind
of a thing I explored was was in I think
I explore with this is just we we all
have these expectations of taboos but
when I'm telling the story I always like
to get to this part because I think it's
the punch line of the story I hired a
translator when I was in Vietnam and one
of the things that delighted me is he
would refer to uh the American War which
I always thought was interesting
um he was injured during the American
War
uh we're at his house
in Hanoi and and they don't have
sidewalks man like this guy lives in
downtown Hanoi
would you step out of his door you gotta
be careful opening the door and stepping
out the door because you're gonna get
run over oh yeah the way this it's
constructed against this street
and he's got we go into his house and
he's got a dog about like it's in a cage
I'm not kidding you man it's about the
size of that table you got next to you
damn with a bowl of rice and a screen
underneath it covered in Sweden like an
excrement trap no not did not look like
it was a breed dog
not like a thit show dog oh wow it was
like a regular dog I came right the
house like a white dog whatever but it
did not look like the meat market dogs
and you'd go to these meat markets
they'd have dog uh dog heads that they'd
burn the hair off
stacked in pyramids I have pictures of
this is [__] that you would not put on
social media I would love to see it I'll
show you but a lot of us just stacked in
pyramids damn but anyways it's just
different way of living and I'll tell
you a little bit more no I don't it's
not wrong no I'm just kidding
yeah we have not eating dog right that's
a luxury he tells no it's
we don't I think if you if
this is this is not a necessity thing
for you for the for the Vietnamese it
never was it was not no it's it's like
it's it's wrong again it's a cultural
it's not a necessity thing it's like
it's like
see I don't watch I don't mean it I
don't want to tell all these stories
acting like I'm talking about someone
being backward it's just like different
[__] you can go to countries where it's
really bad to eat cows okay yes so yes
whatever that's true different people
have different attitudes this guy's
telling me I don't eat dog because I
have a pet dog
and I'm in his home and he's got the dog
and the thing that big and I said to him
so you'll just take it out for a walk
because I was kind of marveling how hard
it is to get in his home because of
traffic and he's like he didn't know
what I meant
he never had that dog out of that box
it was kept like a bird oh wow oh no
it's kept like a it's kept
how you'd keep it torturing this dub
this dog rather be eating but he's like
I don't eat it I have a pet dog oh wow
and that was
it's like that that was so sad that was
like so this relationship then later
went outside in the train and went up
into the mountains and I met a good just
like totally
fortuitous like as crazy as
circumstances where I met this dude and
this guy was actually a hunter that I
met
and he had a small farm in the mountains
outside in the train and they had dogs
and he was in in I was able to
uh
communicate with him
and the way it works he has a farm they
had some cattle they had some pigs they
had chickens they would they would hunt
for these like arboreal marsupials
um they he raised sugar cane
if I remember right he raised corn he
raised a handful of all the crops they
raised Peppers okay all the stuff and
they had dogs and periodically
uh
they don't spay and neuter so
periodically the dogs you keep on your
property will just get too numerous when
they get too numerous there's a guy that
will come around and just like you would
sell just like he would sell chicken to
Market he would sell pork to Market he
would sell cattle to Market he would
sell excess dogs
to Market
and those dogs would enter the same way
his chickens cattle pork would enter the
broader distribution Meat Market it's
just the difference his excess crop of
dogs would enter the
the meat market would enter the meat
market it was just like normal just as
simple as that but you are right like
they'd like so if you were to go to
India certain parts of India you
wouldn't need a cow it'd be sacrilegious
right yeah so there's a lot of examples
of that you know where just some animals
are just taboo and others are not or you
go to certain countries and they don't
want to eat shrimp yep
because God said shrimp have feelings
too so it's yeah like I very much
hesitate to lay this out as it
I I it's I I love talking about it it
was a really interesting experience but
I but it's not and I would never present
it as a backward opinion it's just like
it's it's like our ship looks as crazy
yeah well we let our uh you know they
might look and be like these people when
their parents get old they lock their
parents up that's right yeah and don't
go visit them you want to talk about
somebody talking barbarians or or the
fact that we are we are a nation of
alcoholics and drug addicts I mean you
know comparative yeah so yeah at least
we don't [__] lock our grandpa we've
got a lot of problems we got a lot of
problems there's no doubt yeah that's
interesting um that's pretty wild do you
do a lot of bow hunting more so or no I
mostly no well I like I'll bull hunt a
couple times this year
um but I bow hunt
generally I bow hunt when it's bow
season
meaning
I got friends that are very die-hard
archers
and they'll bow hunt they'll hunt with
their bow
when you could hunt with a gun
right yeah exactly which is great yeah
but I hunt with a bow I like to use the
archery Seasons you know like pretty
soon I'll go hunt
um I'll go hunt whitetails and and uh in
Oklahoma and it'll be like a bow hunt
and it'll be boa season right us bow
hunting deer with my boy the other day
and we were bowing because it was bow
season those gun Seasons we would have
been going hunting yeah so that's my
attitude I use it to like expand my
opportunity what about wolves are you do
you have a lot of wolves in Montana are
they are they making a lot yeah I mean
we have relative to other states in the
lower 48 how many states have wolves
uh so you have wolves in Michigan
Minnesota
Wisconsin Timberwolves huh
well yeah gray wolves um just wallets
man let them get through it different
wolves you have wolves and then you have
so then you have wolves all the North
like
those Northern Tier so you have the
Northern Great Lakes and then you have
wolves all through the Rockies
and then you have wolves down into
um the Mexican gray wolf in Arizona New
Mexico you have a new population of
wolves that just showed up in Colorado
oh boy everything from Colorado North
through the spine of the Rockies but you
have wolves of Washington how big do
they get Oregon you have wolves in
California we have them out here you got
them out here so your guys wolves
they're here in California not here here
but the wolves in California that pop up
those all came from the reintroductions
in the Frank Church Wilderness Area in
Idaho
so they so
the Northern Great Lakes never lost them
um
a lot of the Rockies a lot of the
Southern Rockies lost them and they did
reintroductions in the late 90s into
Yellowstone and Frank church and those
wolves have really spread out and what's
funny is
had they not done that we wouldn't be
quite where we're at right now
but they would have come down through
Canada anyways they would have come in
regardless it wouldn't have happened as
rapidly right this place is like in
Colorado they just
voted in they just passed a referendum
which basically mandates a voter
referendum which basically mandates
Colorado state fish and game agency to
explore and Implement a reintroduction
of wolves
it literally while that that referendum
was on what was going through the ballot
proposal process a new family showed up
yeah wolves came out of Wyoming and
showed up anyway which I thought would
have neutered the whole initiative yeah
but the the initiative still passed so
even though they had wolves naturally
come in
they still are pushing to do this they
accelerated they wreak havoc on Farmers
right well you got to get here yeah they
they the main yeah and there are they
they pull these together these programs
like when you buy a license in Montana
you can you can hunting license in
Montana your eyes prompted to make a
donation to mitigation so the livestock
producer
loses livestock to wolves they can apply
for and receive compensation it's a very
flawed system from a producer's
standpoint because
the producer needs to prove that's what
happened but if you turn 300 cows out on
summer range
and 280 come back
like
you know you're not going to prove what
the hell happened to him so they'll
people are always quick to point out
like oh yeah but they could apply for
conversations like they can but it's you
know you got to prove it yeah and it's
not always able to prove it so there's a
lot it causes a lot of tension with
agricultural producers and when they
first when wolves first get brought into
an area especially when they do these
reintroductions where just boom you know
you see dramatic
dramatic declines yeah I mean I bet like
30 dollars yeah they kill and don't eat
them sometimes right yeah they well yeah
they will they kill a lot of [__] and
what happens is they're
they're
it the wolves are able to come in and
exploit a resource that has no awareness
of wool yeah they have no idea so like
he's like what the hell is that thing
and then you know it's too late and so
you'll see herds you know you'll see
herds of of of 9 000 elk be reduced to
2000 lb herds of 20 000 would be reduced
to nine thousand seriously it's it's
killing five a day or something crazy
yeah well seven pounds of meat a day
that's why they're getting so big well
yeah so like you figure like a wolf's
gonna need seven pounds of meat A Day
damn um how many are there
how many wolves it's usually a family
right yeah so you'll yeah I mean you
know you'll have in some of these areas
so they make these things called
distinct population segments around the
country and you know a DPS is gonna a
distinct population segment would
generally would need to be in the
hundreds to be viable to be really
viables yeah taken out just her like low
hundreds you know but you could you
could get in places I think I don't know
Minnesota's got I think that Minnesota's
at thousands right now and
um it's very hard it's like one of the
most vexing wildlife management issues
in the country
is how do we deal
that that and it's a sociology question
more than anything else a management
sociology is how do you simultaneously
have wolves but
have
um
healthy hunting
right like and have stable big game
populations and and oftentimes if you
argue on behalf of if you're like me and
you argue on behalf of a fairly nuanced
perspective which is that I'm not
anti-predator
um I'd like to see all Native Wildlife
on the ground I'd like to see them
manage and I don't think it's bad to
argue on behalf of big game resources
for human exploitation
but some people be like oh they just
want dear you know those Hunters they
just want deer so they can kill them
then you'd be like uh-huh yeah yeah
that's exactly that's like a thing
that's a thing there's a there's like a
long tradition of hunting deer and Elk
for food
and and so I'm not gonna be bashful
about me saying that that that's a thing
that we're interested in is is ensuring
that we have healthy populations of deer
elk moose because we like to hunt them
at the same time having viable
populations of wolves like we don't have
we don't have an endangered problem in
any any other animals do we well so
they've been the wolf they've been d
the reason they create
that's a great question
with great we talk about
wolves and Grizzlies when they when they
created The Endangered Species Act and
they listed wolves and Grizzlies in the
lower 48 so so Alaska has you know
wolves and Grizzlies occupy like 99 of
historic range in Alaska is just not an
issue
when they list when they gave wolves and
Grizzlies Esa Endangered Species Act
protection in the lower 48 they did it
in a blanket way where they came in and
said basically the lower 48. wolves and
Grizzlies are Esa protected but it
wasn't nuanced enough and a way to think
about it think about like this
elk
are have only been recovered like elk
only occupy I think 20 some 20 some
percent of their historic range meaning
elk were in Michigan Wisconsin all of
Appalachia out to the east coast like
all of the Midwest was elk country elk
were everywhere we've only recovered elk
I don't know what it is 17 of the range
some some [__] like that we recovered
elk on one-fifth of the range but
we hunt elk all over the damn place in
the wet you hunt elk in Kentucky you can
draw elk tags in Michigan you can draw
elk tags in Pennsylvania you can buy elk
tags over the counter in a gas station
in Idaho Montana elsewhere right so
we're hunting elk but we haven't
recovered elk we've only recovered
amount of small portion of the range
when they came in with grizzly bears and
wolves they took this whole lower 48.
and it said endangered
meaning but we're never going to recover
Grizzlies in Golden Gate Park
which is native Grizzly habitat too
dangerous
well yeah way too they don't want them
they're not going to want them yeah the
people that live in Golden Gate Park
don't want you to dump Grizzlies in
Golden Gate Park
so if you can't recover them everywhere
what do you do well you got you got to
go and look like where could they
actually be
right where do we have a chance being
and then manage those places yeah so
we're never going to recover grizzly
bears across their historic range
because you had grizzly bears in Western
Kansas
damn to the California coast and you had
grizzly bears from the Sierra Madre in
Mexico
to the Arctic Ocean
like we're never going to recover them
all the way so what they've done is
they've created these there's six areas
yeah there's six areas that are viable
for Grizzlies I don't know how many
areas are viable for wolves and so the
move now
is to take the isolated pocket not
isolated take the the areas and say
they're recovered there
but not there meaning
they're recovered in the northern
Rockies
but that doesn't mean that they're
recovered in California so remove
protections where they're recovered
um
and don't remove protections where
they're not covered and that approach
when the animal rights groups want to
litigate these issues they attack that
approach
meaning they're saying how could you say
they're recovered here when they're not
recovered everywhere and I'd be like
well uh here's how I can say that we do
it with bighorn sheep we've done it
without we've done with Myriad other
animals it's like there's a lot of work
to be done but that doesn't mean the
work's not taken care of in these areas
in the northern Rockies like wolves are
delisted in the northern Rockies they
have to de-list Grizzlies in the
northern Rockies or else you're a
hypocrite
you know if you push for Grizzly
listening in the first place and you and
you are pro-endangered Species Act you
look like a fool
when are you gonna to not de-list in the
northern rocket when are you going
hunting when he invites me there you go
you want to go I'm down I've never been
we're gonna go I'd go with the
greatest I know yeah wow caught
man-eater yeah I uh I stalk and I rub
myself down in Moss and urine so I've
never been but I feel like I'd slow you
down I don't talk you'd carry all the
stuff yeah okay the stuff you're the
package I'll curiously you would have
zero problems
like physically no I'd be fine oh yeah
you'd have zero problems oh yeah that'd
be fun do you ever Jog and stuff oh yeah
I run all this season you'd smoke me up
a hill yeah he's a monster I don't know
if I'd smoke you but definitely no
you're pretty good I don't think so but
I have one physical talent and it's it's
like walking
not running yeah you can just walk just
like I I do really well at the one foot
in front of the other
marching yeah
I'd be down though yeah there's a lot of
people who could kick my ass
fighting running yeah but I'll I can
just walk walk he'll beat anybody in a
race as long as you don't run yeah yeah
the midday run I'm like
people Crush you in walking uphill just
no there's no trade walking is actually
walking through Briars
trees where would be before we end it
would be a good place to start if I've
never been
like I grew up I grew up like camp and
stuff in you know in Rocky Mountain
stuff like that sounds like it was a
good place
what would be a thing that would be fun
to go do yeah well I'm not miserable I
mean there's just so many things but I
like to suffer a little bit too I don't
want to kill your Cakewalk oh you want
oh
we're we're like filming they're like
all right let's get out of here and
helicopter takes us to Four Seasons I
don't want that no I'm with you yeah we
would go on like maybe like a overnight
little backpack hunt overnight couple we
could even go hunt birds Grouse you want
to hunt something big yeah yeah you want
a rifle you want to be I want to scare
me a little bit if it's a beer I'm like
whatever now Elk elk would be great so
we can get some meat
there we go mule deer hunting you just
include yourself into this I did yeah I
want some music he's got all that urine
and all that he's gonna wipe himself
down wipe himself down wear our
loincloth and the bandana yeah and then
the number one landowner in Jordan yeah
oh no that would be the prince and then
the other one is a New Zealand is a
friend of mine yes of course so we'll go
and Hunt Red Stag in New Zealand well
Stephen we appreciate you coming we know
you got a busy day my man thanks for
having me
yep appreciate it brother great to see
you let's see what you know North
Carolina if you ever want to come there
I'm doing stand up there October 6th and
7th everybody
we're we're in Vegas this week's gank
Fest Friday Saturday Friday Saturday in
Comedy Zone October 6th and 7. Comedy
Zone at the uh Greenboro North Carolina
never been there have you been there can
I plug yeah I go ahead please uh we have
a lot I'm doing a live tour
um which we do periodically this
December oh what do you what do you mean
what are you doing we do theater shows
damn like a podcast where you talk I
kind of like but it's not recorded but
it's like the same kind of
has the same Vibe as my podcast but we
do live q a you got a big black people
ask you questions or no yeah a little
bit in the the first part we do and then
there's like a trivia component we just
cover kind of like news and funny [__]
and it's great yeah we yeah we've done
them we did a lot before the pandemic
but haven't done them since good yeah we
quit we had a whole shitload of shows
and then we canceled them because you
got I mean you guys lived that whole
deal so we're just a little slower to
get back I'm in I'm in Iowa in October
but outside that uh it's gang Fest
Stephen appreciate man thanks a lot
ladies and gentlemen that was awesome